en todo el mundo musulmán las
celebraciones en conmemoración del
nacimiento del profeta mahoma se vieron
opacadas este jueves por la ira contra
el presidente francés emmanuel makoun
lyon hemos venido hoy a rezar en
jerusalén para conmemorar el nacimiento
del profeta y a mostrar nuestro apoyo al
profeta después del insulto que le causó
el presidente de francia donde francia
las tensiones reiniciaron después de que
un profesor de historia mostró
caricaturas del profeta mahoma en una
clase sobre la libertad de expresión su
asesinato por un extremista musulmán
llevó a macua a prometer una campaña de
represión del islamismo radical en
francia y a cerrar mezquitas y
organizaciones acusadas de fomentar la
violencia pero muchos líderes religiosos
dicen que me cuesta apuntando
injustamente a los 5 millones de
musulmanes que se estima hay en francia
y ahora decenas de protestas contra
francia han estallado en buena parte del
mundo musulmán
cada musulmán debe expresar su desdén y
condenar lo que el malvado macrón ha
hecho ha insultado al profeta y ha
insultado lo que consideramos sagrado
este manuel macrón es asqueroso y la
gente lo mira como un hombre repugnante
la liga árabe debe tomar medidas
decisivas para retirar los embajadores
franceses en todos los países para que
makro presente una disculpa a todos los
países árabes e islámicos dorar bien tu
exterior malasia cuya población es
predominantemente musulmana también es
particularmente virulenta contra francia
justo después del ataque a la basílica
de niza el ex primer ministro mattis
mohammad afirmó en twitter que los
musulmanes tenían derecho a estar
enfadados y a matar a millones de
franceses por las masacres del pasado
twitter finalmente retiró el mensaje de
la plataforma después de que francia
pidiera la suspensión total de la cuenta